peter tiede verfolgt für uns die
proteste in weißrussland zu stieß aber
jetzt an der landesgrenze zu litauen
warum stehst du dort weil in
weißrussland gab es kein netz warum das
weil die tat tatsächlich mit allen
mitteln arbeitet er hat einfach das
internet ausgeschaltet das ist möglich
man muss sich notenpunkte einfach nur
wie lahm legen und dann kommt man hier
dann hat man zwar ausschlag aber man
kommt tatsächlich mit dem handy nicht
ins netz man kommt selbst von
kabelgebundenen computer nicht ins netz
weißrussland ist so eine außenwelt was
das internet angeht abgeschottet und die
oppositionsführerin nach kaya hält sich
nicht mehr in weißrussland auch sie soll
in litauen sein weiß man mehr über ihren
aufenthaltsort
also sie wird so ist die offizielle
beschreibung deshalb muss auch
diplomaten jetzt bestätigt betreut
im außenministerium betont sie ist
gestern ausgereist man weiß man dass sie
16 uhr
weissrussischer zeit hier bei der
zentralen wahlkommission war zusammen
mit dem anwalt und mit einer ihrer ihrer
mitstreiterin dann hat der anwalt allein
das gebäude verlassen dann kam stunden
später hat sich ihre mitstreiterin
gemeldet und tieren oscar war wie vom
erdboden verschluckt wie wir jetzt
wissen ist sie wohl außer landes
gebracht worden es gibt unterschiedliche
darstellungen die einen sagen dass das
litauische behörden waren andere sagen
das weiß was sie selber sie
herausgebracht hat die offizielle
darstellung hier in weißrussland ist das
weißrussischen behörden sie über die
grenze gebracht hätten was jetzt holt
wissen wir nicht wir wissen nur sie ist
bei ihren kindern ihre zwei kinder einen
sohn eine tochter hat sie vorher der
wahl schon ins ausland gebracht der mann
ist er noch im gefängnis und jetzt hat
es offensichtlich keinen anderen ausweg
gesehen als das land zu verlassen und
sie hat sich jetzt auch in einer
videobotschaft geäußert dass das wurde
auf twitter veröffentlicht da wollen wir
einmal kurz reinhören
ja der kampagne
usability sebastian ist da war dass ich
als priester
ja zitierte sommer
was hat das denn für eine signalwirkung
werden die oppositionsführerin sagt dass
die nachricht vor einer schwache frau
ist peter das ist natürlich eine ganz
dramatische aussage und in der diktatur
ist man daran gewöhnt ansprache mit
doppeltem boden mit verschiedenen
aussagen wenn sie sagt sie ist eine
schwache frau dann heißt das natürlich
sie waren die große oppositionsführern
sie ist für jemand eingesprungen sie ist
dann in die rolle rein gedrängt worden
und sie konnte auch nicht mehr zurück
und sie hat die wahl selbst völlig
überrascht davon dass als sie zu einer
demonstration aufgerufen hat man
plötzlich 60.000 menschen in dienst auf
der straße waren etwas sind 30 jahren in
weissrussland niemals gegeben hat das
ist ein enormer druck dann dort gibt es
diese wahl fällt und dann gehen die
menschen auf die straße und dann gibt es
gewalt von von staatsseite dann werden
menschen verletzt dann werden menschen
getötet und dann stehst du da wirklich
als frau die früher nie im rampenlicht
stand und all diese last bis auf ihr und
dann geht es der staatlichen
wahlkommission
dann gibt es so genannte gespräche mit
behördenvertretern und da wird man hier
schon einiges klargemacht haben und das
sagt auch diese aussage aus eigentlich
sie spricht ja auch von ihren kindern
die kinder sind da sind das wichtigste
und sie muss natürlich zu den kindern
und sie hat einen ehemann im gefängnis
und das ist natürlich ein enormer druck
und natürlich wird in solchen
situationen auch druck ausgeübt mit der
tatsache
denken sie an diamanten im gefängnis
denken sie an ihre kinder diese im
ausland denken sie daran wie die kinder
aufwachsen sollen das ist üblich und
dann gab es da noch etwas ausgereizt die
meldung kam offiziell ihren oscar ja das
land verlassen und kurz darauf ist ihre
engste vertraute freigelassen worden die
kurz vor der wahl verhaftet worden
worden war
das ist alles umstände die darauf
hindeuten dass das regime eine klare
ansage gemacht also entweder verlässt du
jetzt das land oder aber es geht auch
den leuten die du kennst die mit ihr
verbündete sind und die im gefängnis
sind jetzt an den jetzt an den kragen